I have no interest in an inferior
martini the last time I saw you you said
you have to come and make a martini in
Charleston which we're going to do only
et was invited inside a southern charm
star Patricia all Shoals at South
Carolina's mansion
you mentioned martini by the martini
master yes and it were this is where
it's done this is the butler's pantry so
for an exclusive a martini making
tutorial from Patricia's Butler Michael
he makes the best one and believe me I
have tasted quite a few in my day so
what all goes into the perfect if you
some people like it light some people
like a heavy and mrs. a likes it in the
middle and contrary to public thought I
do not start at breakfast Michael has
all the essentials at the ready
including the secret ingredient French
vermouth
when did the martini become your
signature drink 1902 and Patricia's
martinis are strictly gin not vodka
vodka is made out of a lowly potato and
gin has 18 botanicals Ginevra you know
there 18 of them so when I say medicine
I mean it it's very healthy
[Music]
you rang madam it's time for my medicine
if you please
so in a shaker you mix a few shots of
that medicine with a shot of vermouth
depending on how strong you want your
drink then crush ice cubes using the
Lewis ice bag Michaels other martini
secret the ice should be the size of
tiny tiny shivers of glass the ice goes
into the glasses along with the zest of
a lemon and you always Rim the glass
with the lemon to make sure you get a
little bit of flavor so every every sip
should be at a different point on the
glass and now it's time to shake your
liquor mix then pour you see they're
poured up right to the edge yes and
enjoy two southern charm area the full
recipe can be found in Patricia's new
book the art of southern charm
you